there was so much great TV right now
really fantastic yeah it's hard to keep
up with all of it it's also good it's
also good I don't know if you've seen
he's seen going clear that documentary
on Scientology I've seen it 16 times 16
times I guess you really liked it it's a
bunch of crap Conan crap it's a great
expose on Scientology they barely
scratched the surface they left a lot of
stuff out
the fact is Scientology's a secret arm
of the Central Intelligence Agency back
in 2000 Scientology and the CIA
manipulated the election that put George
W Bush in the White House okay Eddie
what are you talking about oh come on
it's right before your eyes Conan you've
just got to open them now look the
Church of Scientology CE OS what does
that spell cops who is cause Bill Cosby
and where's Bill Cosby from Philadelphia
where was the 2000 Republican condensed
convention held Philadelphia
Oh some of the yarn went down oh my god
ten years walk down the drain stupid
cheap yarn wow that's tough luck Andy
next time use lanagin's conspiracy on
lanagin's casino on is a secret blend of
wool and nylon polymers that make a 40
percent stronger than the leading
competitor so you can build your
elaborate paranoid theories with
confidence and if the CIA or KGB or the
other side or the Singapore mob or the
Vatican get you before you can tell the
world others will be able to pick up the
trail ladies and gentlemen a lanagin's
is the best isn't that right every guy
who's six next to you and you take a
long trip on a Greyhound bus it sure is
Conan lanagin's conspiracy yarn is the
only yarn I trust to connect the dots
and keep them connected oh I should have
used lanagin's
you